ou Nicole Kidman apparemment elle
demande des bouteilles d'eau minérale
Évian afin qu'elle puisse se rincer les
cheveux en évitant le chlore et le
calcaire
on a l'habitude de dire nous quand on va
au Festival de Cannes tout ce qui est
tout ce qui se passe à Cannes rester à
Cannes parce que à chaque fois on voit
des trucs énormes
on voit des trucs énormes nous on vit
des trucs un peu spéciaux moi je l'ai
fait plusieurs fois et c'est vrai que on
a des stars qui sont assez perchées ou
des soirées qui sont assez démentes
alors Mariah Carey elle avait demandé la
privatisation de l'espace première
classe d'un avion pour son voyage oui
c'est vrai 85000 euros
Jack Nicholson aussi une fois qui a
demandé d'ailleurs à Canal plus de lui
payer un jet privé sinon il se venait
pas sur la Croisette nicholsonaire
[Rires]
dans des hôtels très spéciaux très très
très houpées on est plus des pigeons
il y a eu
une histoire aussi avec Canal+ et une
célèbre actrice française à l'époque qui
avait demandé à aller à l'Eden Rock qui
est un des hôtels
de la côte d'Azur et donc elle avait dit
elle avait dit à Michel Denisot à
l'époque si je ne vais pas aller dunrock
je si je ne vais pas les dunrogue je ne
viens pas faire les missions etc donc
ils ont accepté sauf qu'elle a laissé
une autre pharaonique à l'hôtel donc
ça serait passé avec nous oui
[Musique]
il y a quelques années Eva avait réservé
toute une boutique de chaussures de luxe
pour faire son shopping sans être
dérangé plus de 20000 € bravo Eva
tu as raison
voilà je te le dis bravo tu fais ce que
tu veux Madonna ouais elle s'était
particulièrement énervée à chaque fois
c'était rendu compte qu'il n'y avait pas
de salle de sport dans son hôtel elle
avait exigé qu'on lui en installe une
ils ont installé une salle de sport pour
Madonna dans l'hôtel il y avait pas de
salle de sport ils ont dit vas-y c'est
un truc de fou c'est incroyable
particulier c'est incroyable alors on va
vous révéler les prix des hôtels aussi
parce que en fonction de l'hôtel où vous
êtes on sait si vous êtes un taulier par
exemple il faut savoir que Martinez et
de Niro ils étaient à l'Hôtel du Cap
Eden rock c'est le top du tétaulier
voilà c'est le nouvel hôtel
quand on travaille dans la presse people
parce que c'est là où on a les plus
belles photos comme ça c'est privé les
viennent en bateau ils viennent en
bateau il une espèce de cascade ou les
gens se baignent en bateau pour parce
que la piscine
en fait ils viennent directement avec un
parce que
moi
là-bas
[Rires]
il y a plein d'hôtels et les prix
pendant le festival dépendent du type de
chambre les prix en festivals bien sûr
sont moins chers et là c'est vrai que
c'est un truc de fou alors il y a il y a
le Mariotte par exemple or festival
c'est de 250 euros à 2000 euros la nuit
pendant le festival c'est de 2000 à 5000
donc c'est voilà
minimum le Martinez c'est de 300 à 1500
euros très sympa aussi je les aimerait
bien et sinon c'est de 2000 euros à 9000
euros le Martin c'est très gentil
exactement
le Majestic très bien le Majestic aussi
de 700 à 4000 euros et sinon c'est de
3000 à 8000 euros et le de 700 à 5000
euros super le Calton c'est de 5000
euros à 25000 euros c'est que des hôtels
magnifiques non mais je vous dis et
après il y a l'Ibis à Cannes et ben même
pendant le festival
il est de 73 € à 170 € normalement c'est
de 120 200 €, tu vois maintenant le
festival en fait c'est tu te fais Airbnb
explose il y a une chambre de 44 m² qui
a vu sur le tapis à 11500 euros la nuit
donc là on attend des prix totalement
stratosphériques
quand on est des rédactions parce que en
général ce qu'on fait c'est on y va à
plusieurs plusieurs journalistes parce
que les les appartements coûte hyper
cher c'est genre 10000 euros la semaine
quoi donc où sont les stars alors aucun
tonne il y a Johnny Depp parce qu'il
viendrait ouvrir après 3 ans de trois
mots ils ont fait des très beaux travaux
bravo il y a Michael Douglas Harrison
Ford il y a Naomi Campbell Catherine
Deneuve Lily-Rose Depp au Majestic il y
a Léonardo Dicaprio ah non Martin scores
il est passé
[Rires]
Pierre Richard pierre nine Vincent Lebas
Eric Judor encore Maïwenn au Martinez
c'est la plupart des influenceurs il y
avait également Orelsan je le sais et
les énormes tôliers je vous le dis ça
part sur le Cap d'Antibes c'est les
dents tout y compris
les plus grandes stars par un peu
DiCaprio est-ce qu'il paye sa chambre ou
est-ce que l'hôtel pour la
publierai en fait rien du tout que ça
soit le yacht que ça soit la chambre
d'hôtel que ça soit la tenue en charge
tout de même et maison de production
deux jours c'est d'accord qui paye deux
nuits après il se débrouille soit c'est
la production
le festival paye de nuit vraiment et
après s'ils veulent rester là c'est la
production il se débrouille avec la
production notamment DiCaprio qui veut
toujours rester à Lidl rock il est allé
dan rock il veut rester la semaine avec
sa mère en général la raison et ouais
c'est magnifique
il y a des arrangements puisque ça fait
de la publicité pour l'hôtel magnifique
il y a deux cours de tennis en terre
battus
[Rires]
on vous a fait une compile des
principales stars qui ont été aperçues
dans leur hôtel respectifs regardez et
après on viendra sur la terre
[Applaudissements]
ça va
[Musique]
donc
non mais c'est voilà donc il y avait
Nabilla aussi qui est professionnel de
Cannes
tu es très belle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et avant qu'on vienne sur l'altercation
il y a aussi une femme vêtue d'une robe
aux couleurs du drapeau de l'Ukraine qui
a fait éruption hier soir sur le tapis
rouge avec cet asperger de faux sang
regardez
[Musique]